ich habe letztens eine 3000 € Saturn wo
dann Tüte mit doppeltem Warenwert
gekauft und das war drin 6000 € sein und
bin gespannt Leute man muss sagen eine
Sache die kann ich euch jetzt schon
verraten weil das habe ich direkt
gesehen hier ist ein Dyson hot and cool
das ist doch so Luftreiniger oder die
sind auf jeden Fall sehr gefragt aktuell
den haben die halt einfach so
mitgeschickt kostet ungefähr 600 €. ich
blende euch die Preise hier mal ein ihr
kennt das ganze und dann machen wir uns
jetzt gleich mal an die anderen Pakete
ja gut also ich könnte ihn jetzt
auspacken oder halt nicht nee machen wir
mal weiter also das Ding ist auf jeden
Fall ultra schwer KitchenAid Küchenhilfe
boah junge was ist das denn so sieht das
Ganze aus KitchenAid wir haben hier den
4,8 Liter artisen Gerät ne okay gut ich
finde den jetzt hier für 400 9,99 € bis
599 € gut sagen wir mal 400 € kostet das
Ding kommen wir zu diesem Paket ich
glaube aber da ist das gleiche drin ihr
seht schon dasselbe Gerät